welcome back to christmas in the 10
million dollar studio have you ever seen
a take so bad it actually ruins your day
like you're just on twitter reading the
news and you see an opinion so backwards
so terrible it physically disturbs you
well
not the brag but i have and i feel
compelled to share with you i'm gonna
set the stage for you guys but first
pump the stock please it's christmas in
the 10 million dollar studio we're
trying to get to 1 million subscribers
this month and if we do we're going to
be able to give a bunch of money to
charity but without further ado onto the
video
so here's how it happened i just watched
mr beast's squid game in real life if
you haven't seen it it's incredible
basically won the internet for the day
and i had commented square game in real
life is the youtube video of the year
amazing attention to detail and hard to
believe how fast they did this mr beast
is changing the game now this is not a
controversial statement right it's like
saying the sky is blue every person i
knew was basically saying the same thing
that day i mean they just nailed
everything from wardrobe to vfx even the
small safety stuff were just in place
it was perfect and they made youtube
look good they gave away money and they
entertained a lot of people what could
be wrong with that wtf your bio says i
want to make the world a better place
before i die talking about mr beast but
you're wasting money and resources on
building some random squid game you
could give millions of dollars to
everyone so no one is poor but instead
you waste it on this stupid game now
before we get into how bad this take is
look i get it it's just one voice right
that wouldn't bother me except that
apparently so many people felt this way
that it made the actual news youtube
star mr beast criticized for 3.5 million
dollar real life squid game the social
media star stirred up controversy after
sharing the 25 minute long video of
squid game in which 456 contestants
battled it out to win 456 000
and this just set me off because the
whole thing here right um fundamentally
is basically that mr beast hasn't
donated enough or should have just taken
the money he was going to spend on this
and just donated it to charity now of
course if these people had done an ounce
of research they'd know that's what mr
beast is known for doing his entire
brand is donating to charity exactly one
day before he launched this squid game
video that so many people are mad at him
for he fed ten thousand people with
turkey dinners through his charity uh
beast philanthropy and by the way the
only reason that works is because of his
high media profile
which is created through videos like
squid game so the irony is he wouldn't
be able to donate so much money if he
didn't do the videos that he did but on
top of that people are criticizing this
guy for not donating enough right as
he's in the middle of raising 30 million
dollars for ocean cleanup as well
through team seas i mean that's the guy
you're trying to attack that's the guy
you're leveling the claim of you're not
donating enough for
people by the way who are just keyboard
warriors i mean what have they done like
accusing mr beast of not donating enough
is like accusing the pope of not being
catholic enough it doesn't even make
sense logically mathematically the proof
is not there the guy's entire brand is
built around giving money and it's not
even just on camera i mean i've
personally talked to mr beast i know a
ton of people who have met him too and
everyone just says the same thing off
camera on camera he's just a really
genuine guy trying to help and it's even
to the point where people criticizing
him seems self-aware of the fact that
yeah this is super unpopular to say and
there's almost nothing controversial
here but i'm gonna still find a reason
to criticize this guy anyway i mean like
look take a look at this raising money
to clean the oceans the beaches and the
rivers
who could argue with that seriously who
could argue with that
well i'm about to
i mean
you can't even make this up because who
could argue with it well i will um he
goes on to say that because mr beast
eats meat and isn't vegan um 30 million
dollars in fundraising is a bad thing
yes you heard it right that's the
headline guy does good thing but is not
an actual human saint so therefore he's
terrible
i mean you could literally do this about
anything like this guy's thing happens
to be veganism but um you could be a
vegan and you drive a car to work okay
so you're a terrible person now because
you drive a car so nothing positive you
do with veganism is good because you
happen to drive a car or maybe you bike
to work but you don't recycle all eight
different types of recyclable material i
mean we could just go add infinitum it's
just oh you exist and you're breathing
oxygen what a monster i mean look
sometimes just things aren't that deep
sometimes there are just good things in
the world that we can all celebrate
without pulling out our sophomore
criticism and instead we could just try
to enjoy something but instead everybody
who does this is apparently a hypocrite
if they are also not vegan and
contributing to the climate crisis does
mr beast really get about the
environment or is he just doing this
team c's campaign to raise his profile
and all these other influencers making
these nice little team seize videos do
any of them actually make any
differences in their own personal lives
are any of them actually practicing what
they preach are they just editing and
putting out these nice little videos to
raise their own profiles and make
everyone think there's some kind of
saints whilst doing next to nothing to
actually help with the issues i mean
this guy is really reaching here a lot
of assumptions are being made about how
much actual personal action people are
doing in their lives and while i think
it's important to highlight the fact
that people need to make personal
changes in their lives it's also so
incredibly disingenuous to just
absolutely dump on anyone doing anything
positive in a public way just because oh
oh they might not be doing everything
right in their private life and by the
way he doesn't even know that that's
actually what triggers me about this
whole thing is like he's just making the
assumption that oh these people must be
terrible they must be awful like it
seems to me like if you're in 2021 and
you're not a monk living in the hills on
all solar energy if you even try to
donate any kind of money to people
you're going to be seen as human trash
and videos are going to be made about
how bad of a person you are i guess i
just think there are so many worse
things we could be solving or trying to
uh or trying to address and instead
we're just quibbling about a guy who
gives to charity and like talking about
how controversial that is i really don't
understand it i don't get it it seems to
me that a lot of the people who
criticize mr beast they say that they
want from their influencers people who
are using their platform for good
donating a lot of their personal money
and that's just what mr beast is doing
so it's like people ask for something it
shows up and then those same people say
not good enough i don't know i guess i
just don't understand it uh you know
it's not to say that mr peace is never
going to do anything uh criticizable but
it just feels like people want him to
actually be a worse person than he is so
they can like then go aha we got you
it's
that's stupid so hey that's it uh i'm
gonna just link the charity drive below
team c's for those who want to donate i
think it's a good cause raising 30
million dollars for ocean cleanup i
think it's cool oh and by the way uh
just as an addition i'm adding this
after the fact i filmed this all before
the beginning of the month i know mr
beast commented on
her channel randomly saying like uh
remind me when the to boost the subs or
something like that which is dope but i
shot this before that i don't want
anyone to think like i'm on you know mr
b's payroll or anything because you know
that is that is absolutely not the case
i would never
never take money like that so um just so
everyone knows it's absolutely no
conflict of interest here so that's
basically it thanks for watching
[Music]